in a long time date I know you're I
guess still in LA and you're on the road
yeah um how are things it was good man I
just came back and did Radio City a
couple of weeks back yeah yeah I saw
your uh your tweet you enjoyed it
oh my god it was you know one of those
gigs that you kind of like overhype it
it's too much you're so excited or you
think about it you know a little bit too
long it can happen sometimes you have
like a TV gig to and you're sowing your
head about it
and it was you know I'm like it's Radio
City and the marquee and the you know
the whole thing and then like within a
minute of my set I grabbed the mic to
move it and it broke what and it was
just one of those things I'm like and I
said onstage her mic this is [ __ ]
Radio City and they're like it's
breaking and I looked over the side the
guy would just don't like this some guy
I don't even know who was in charge of
the mic yeah you couldn't touch it he
has to bring it out right yeah but it it
like put me in the right headspace to
like be like okay I'm just now I'm just
gonna rant for a second even though it's
Radio City and you're kind of out there
or iam now it just came just a big hall
with broken [ __ ] so many bigger gigs in
that that for you like that's not as
overwhelming as it would be for other
comics cuz you've seen crowds it's like
it's not that's not you know it's really
yeah it's it more than anything it's
it's not necessarily the crowd size it's
just that for me it's I don't know how I
know everybody's different but like I
know the minute I walk into a gig like
into the dressing room if I'm in the
right
you know like memento what is that like
momentum and headspace yeah I know right
away I can just feel it and that was one
of those days Rose like the second I got
in there I'm like I don't know what's
like if I'm like low blood sugar here or
something but it just I felt it I really
did more than throw you what's that what
can throw you like what's something that
will say out [ __ ] now I'm not in this
place I need to be ah dude it's so weird
because I I've always been like a better
under pressure kind of performer and
I've had definitely like whether it's
the size of the event or the
the the pressure for me to perform
because either there is like a love or
an animosity my worst gigs are when I
walk in I'm kind of flat and chill like
if I'm really relaxed huh and and I
don't have a lot of like back against
the wall in my head that's pretty bad
man
hi so those are the worst gigs over the
years when you feel calm when I'm really
relaxed yeah when I just kind of saunter
a lot of people yeah I I just I've
always had that thing where it's like
you know somebody could be like
screaming in my face before about
something and I'm completely distracted
and then I go out there and those are
the ones that always for whatever he's
intentionally that shot out of a cannon
energy yeah I've always dug that yeah
yeah do you know one of the best shows I
had in a while I was in Australia I was
pissing I remember this show and they
announced my name it was in midstream
and I'm like there's no way and I know
there's a panic sets in when there's the
music's playing and you're not walking
out host is there so I'm filling my cup
I take my piss I want my managers
panicking I made fun of him for panic
what the [ __ ] you gonna do I'm pissed
and that that weird thing that happened
that's stress right before of knowing it
made the gig amazing right it just
opened up with something I didn't plan
opening up with and you're talking about
something and you're thinking about
something other than the size of the gig
or other than what I'm really doing up
here which is hoping it doesn't go
poorly and it put you in the right
headspace yeah I just it's kind of cool
when you don't you think - that's also a
product of you know obviously we came up
and and I came out of Boston which was
very rambunctious and you kind of had to
you know fight past other guys that were
just up there slaying and then come to
New York City and everybody's [ __ ]
busting balls and it's like if you lean
back then they sense it and then you get
hazed and I just feel like we're just
pressure players where it's like it's
better for us if there is some kind of
Anarchy going on in distraction yes yeah
like I love one of like somebody just
told me like a fight happened right
before the Radio City gig yeah and I
heard when I got out there and the thing
with the mic and I
I still heard they were settling people
down I don't know who's fighting when
they go to Radio City but Roland just
home he's like two two girls got in a
huge fight and I knew what Rowland was
saying I like Roland needs to come with
closed captioning digital shirt that
actually like hears him through a Mikan
but you like that I do there's something
and now I have to grab the audience
right now dude I don't know man I'm just
you know it's not - I'm not I'll try to
be as like nun bummer about this but
like the night my dad died it was like I
was on stage and I had an amazing set
even though I had all that on my mind
and it was like this heavy you know just
I don't know I am more comfortable in my
skin being uncomfortable did you tell
the audience that he died oh yeah you
did be on the beginning or what part of
the set um I was about maybe 10 minutes
in and I finally was like hey just you
know full disclosure and of course they
laughed
nobody really right believed that I
would be up there at first doing this
setup where's he going
ever
for no punchline in particular about my
pop but it was just the set itself was
like I don't know I just remember coming
off and being like okay I'm I'm good
under pressure I guess do you know when
Joan Rivers husband committed suicide
she said the one thing she wanted to do
is go on she couldn't because everybody
knew what it just happens and it
would've been too weird but she's like
all I wanted to do is just cause it's
got to be nice that you have that
distraction where you're not allowed to
kind of sit there and think about what's
actually going on in your life like you
have to be concentrating on what you're
doing so for the next hour you aren't
allowed to think about the fact that
this terrible thing just happened you're
there and it's the ultimate distraction
right right and yet as how many years
are you in now since the 1999
yeah I'm 29 29 no no 1990 29 yeah yeah I
started yeah I sort speakeasy
we get thrown the hoosegow
it's that thing - it's like you know
after all those years of of you know
just consistently getting up there and
putting ourselves not only on stage
which is pressure but having to I know
the worst day of your life is that you
brought to the stage but it's it it is
kind of a dare I say magical thing of
like this is comedy and tragedy right
now at its heightened
most heightened you sometimes they don't
understand how like what you're really
thinking when you're saying those things
like there's been times Robin I was
amazed like they have no idea that I'm
actually really saying this like it or
that I'm kidding as much as I have but
right raisi things that have gone
through my head on stage that have no
connection to my Joker yeah I don't know
what it is I got all be getting a laugh
or a joke won't work I don't think of
something that I know I can't say out
loud yeah there's got to be a freedom in
that I guess that you can say things out
loud cuz you there's like the people
will go oh he's probably just joking and
you go yeah maybe I was it wasn't yes
but you can say those things that you
couldn't possibly get offstage and just
say at a table with people we have to
address things to like and humor like if
your dad dies or if your your girlfriend
dumps you like singers are easy they're
lucky you know I want to dedicate this
song it's called mother where are you
[ __ ] sing there nice song that
they've already had right do thats right
they can't change the words depending on
how they're feeling when they hit the
stage that night right yeah yeah I guess
I think like you can go up there and
talking you talk about like oh yeah
thing about killing myself the other day
and nobody's sitting there going like Oh
Jim do you need do you need somebody to
talk to cuz they'll just sit there and
watch you work through it and tell jokes
about it yeah right let's take you to
see a guy in the front row like a
shit-eating grin like people really get
it and they really understand it I
become it's funny with Boston guys so
many funny guys coming to Boston it's
such a great place for stand-up yeah
I've been kind of looking on YouTube
because every guy in Boston talks about
Gavin and Sweeney those are the guys and
there's a lot of other ones but those
are the two main yeah and I really have
never watched either one of those guys
perform I met Steve Sweeney once I don't
think I've ever met Gavin but I've seen
little clips of them online and they're
both really really
funny but I wish there was more [ __ ] of
them online to watch because I wanna I
want to really watch a full set for one
of those I will tell you though those
clips don't like they don't do it any
Josh
I'm sure man when I it they would have
the kind of Steve Sweeney in particular
but Gavin pretty much as equally he
would have those sets where if you Fung
yourself really like why after like 20
minutes you you'd be like I should quit
right I'm leaving I want to [ __ ]
leave here right now god I don't want to
go up I can't do that like he start to
make you believe right that you have no
abilities I'm not doing that right now
very easy perform watch them at
something I guess he's a casually really
funny dude Sweeney I was like what a
great performer yeah yeah but the whole
thing to like voices sounds you know
energy the movement like kind of I grew
up loving Carlin I just like somebody
who's kind of bombastic and has you know
thinking man but at the same time you
know have you ever woken up and your
dick and balls are all stuck you're like
listen to somebody talk about the most
you know mundane gross [ __ ] and you're
like okay then they can switch gears
that's kinda what those guys did they
were able to you know talk about stuff
that was poignant and today and then
just going these [ __ ] crazy rants
that the walls would be shaking in these
clubs did you get to a place where you
all of a sudden started seeing young
guys not copying you but kind of emulate
like there were there guys that would
pop up and you're like oh he's kind of
doing me I'm becoming that guy the
younger comics are looking at going like
I want to do that I did I did and I for
me I always thought it was kind of
flattering because I came up there were
certain you know comics that I loved and
okay to be able to own the stage or move
around like at any Murphy or to be able
to tell I love long-form storytelling
yes always what I really wanted to be I
wanted to be able to tell a story that
could be 15 minutes long but there's
breaks and there's still observational
outside [ __ ] that is in part of the
lineage of the you know the story that's
always where I wanted to emulate and get
to so the you know Cosby's and new
hearts and guys that could keep you in
Oh kind of hypnotized by something that
was gonna take a little bit longer to
have a payoff you know and when I see it
now I I I never I never got
I never got upset in other comics like
maybe some people did about me and I
don't know if that has to do with just
maybe the time in comedy or what I
accomplished I'm sure it's different or
you know everybody has an opinion
actually I know everybody but I never
have had the vitriol against somebody
else that I felt like I found with my
have you talked to anybody who had that
towards you cuz it was an interesting to
watch like guys got so I guess cuz you
you you were the first one yeah MySpace
but you were the first one to really use
social media as a comedian and and make
it this way of gonnit going around what
the business model of your industry is
and and we're credit for that because
you're the first dude to really do it
yeah and the fact that like you started
appealing first peoples don't get any
credit normally and then right now you
know that it's usually the second person
who comes along and like really make
capitalizes it right the first person
who does it cheated that's not how you
do it he's a social he's like on MySpace
it's not college kids like it's not real
like he just clicked a button any film
ever gonna mug
okay do it yeah before comics were
really doing that it was that that whole
period was it was wonderful it was great
to see it play out like that and if
nothing else I just like I like that
more comedians today are entrepreneurial
and used that all I did was use a part
of the day that for a number of years we
maybe didn't you know invest in I think
that you got to get up and you got to do
something like this but elite is a thing
yeah yeah you gotta you got to connect
with people in some capacity people do
you because then there's some guys that
you're like [ __ ] they don't have now
you don't anymore if you're like well
you know what it depends I don't know
yeah you could say both yes I think at
one point everyone has to where people
lose interest when you're young you do
yeah once you don't have to keep doing
it though like once you have your
audience I think there are a lot of
people that don't have to keep doing it
Chappelle's a rare exception to that
rule he doesn't have to at all like he
just kind of
goes up does a special yeah and that's
it he can comment on he doesn't have to
comment on it everybody will talk about
it for him some want to crucify him some
are happy did it bother it bothered you
as a comic we're sensitive you know to
criticism did you have you talked to
anybody who was shitty to you and
there's no longer shitty - um I've
talked to a few people that you know
Hedstrom strong opinions and most of
them it's it's not to get into the weeds
on it but like people will come to me be
like dude I was in a I was in a crazy
fucked-up place in my life or I had
somebody approach me and just be very
honestly say I was so sick of doing like
radio for my own gigs wherever I was
middle of nowhere just charging away and
the first question a DJ would be like
why are you doing this [ __ ] [ __ ]
he and I think there was a little bit of
weird resentment or competitiveness or
something that you know the insecurities
that we all I don't know we're such
complex you know creatures man it's it's
uh I I don't when people come to me I
want to name names so bad but at the
same time I have an AB I just don't want
to put anybody in like a weird but you
know people economy dude at the second
somebody reaches out their hand and says
like hey can we you know can we move
past this or talk about it like I you
know and maybe you've heard stories I'm
like yeah let's let's squash it it's
what were they verbal if they were
publicly vocal against you and they came
to you and you guys actually had a nice
talk that's okay to name somebody cuz I
think you're actually saying that the
person who was public about this note is
it's a good thing yeah I just respect
comedy I remember like I remember Morgan
Murphy who I didn't know very well but I
thought was great and she sat next to me
at the club randomly one night and she
just like was like hey I just want to
take ownership over like I was one of
those people that without knowing you
was on the attack and Bubble Boy and
like instantly I was like yeah I was
like I'm glad you told me and it's you
know it's that's completely cool and I
think if we all go through you know I've
had every kind of up and down - man you
know I've been on the inside outside you
know it's sometimes it's even Wilder
when you have an opportunity to hit a
high-water mark in your life because you
know the only way
the place that is gonna go is down to
another something where you got to
rebuild yeah so it's there's like
there's no right there's no safe you
know what like in a club there's no one
comfortable place to [ __ ] stand
there's no one care place
to really be until you get out of there
right and that's I think a career are
you still doing thousands of like you're
still doing legitimately good gigs and I
remember touring with dice in the 90s
and you know he had done the Garter
you've done all these amazing things and
he was still doing like he was so I want
to say obsessed with getting back into
the garden and those but say cancer
you're still doing three to five six
dozen like you still have an amazing
[ __ ] career not specifying you had a
great career and you're still you almost
have to let that that whatever it is
blow up happen oh you got everything
settled to be like okay this is a really
good space here that's not like a just a
choice and then you're like let me plug
that back in it's like if that's if
that's a direction it's going in and you
want to you know embrace that like like
I did of course of course yes these were
the guys that I loved when it started
happening I was like [ __ ] yeah yeah but
I think that it's also about evolution
and then taking that energy for me it's
like dude I love stand-up I did
everything I ever wanted to do in
stand-up comedy I hosted SNL that was
kind of it the device right the thing
yeah and of course Madison Square Garden
every garden every arena finally got to
the Radio City but when people ask me
now like what are you really striving
towards it's like I'm directing films
now I'm putting my energy into young
performers comics you know kind of like
help them to I did just did a film with
a guy has nothing to do with my life not
a story I would tell it's more exciting
to to set a goal like that that I've
never done as opposed to not trying to
get back into the garden if the garden
calls yeah well we'll figure it out if
that's supposed to be but otherwise I'm
having the time of my life you're happy
doing other stuff as well cuz you really
have nothing to prove as a stand-up I
mean everybody knows what you've
accomplished how many specials you like
it's not like you got to go out there
and show people hey I'm a draw everybody
knows that so there's other [ __ ] you
just want to you
yeah the evolution is pretty clear like
the fact that you're still doing it and
still and getting completely coming up
with new material at a time and and your
being who you are now it's not like you
go on stage today and try to be the guy
from 10 15 years throwing some bootcut
jeans feather my hair back get the white
it's like no Madame 47 dude and I say it
a lot on stage I'm like yeah I'm just
starting to get the pains and the you're
leaning into that second act doesn't
suck till I say it to cause it's like I
want to just get it out of it and you're
almost hoping you say the people go no
but they don't we notice I'm glad you
say I'm 51 and that one head is
surprised as long as you're thinner than
your audience then you'll feel great I
can never not be fitter than my audience
I can never if I'm not fitter than my
audience I'm probably dead
but 29 years in and by the way just like
side note I have so many of those old
like NACA in Boston comedy club fliers
and all those things with all of us on
there and save it all right I got it all
man it's it's yeah that whole era very
very cool but 29 years in when when
people do a meet and greet or whatever
and come up to me they're like oh I saw
you at the garden I saw you whatever
it's like I'm psyched because I'm going
I had a few tools and I was on the seat
of my pants and I had like youthful
exuberance
but I'm seasoned now in a way and I can
tell a story and like there's so much
I'm so much better yeah I still I still
for me and like oh there's other things
I want to be able to obtain but the the
place that I wanted to get to more than
anywhere was being able to like still
have the natural energy in performance
but but but something I saw guys like
Patrice have so early even Chapelle was
like introspection mm-hmm to be able to
like slow down and tell a story like
plant the feet and just be right here
and if I want to go into some kind of
movement around it's like it can be part
of it but to have both of those things
together and keep a crowd like you know
as kind of in
i'm cherdon excited I feel like it's the
best time for me I've ever had as a
performer it's hard to do I am not good
at storytelling I've never been a good
storyteller I no matter what I'm talking
about I'm like they're losing interest
I'm losing interest and I'm right like I
know I know what I'm good at and that's
not it like I admire guys you can do
that I feel the same way about like the
people who can just figure out that
haiku of like it's it's amazing well you
watch Rodney yeah he wasn't a story tell
you what's right in tonight's show was
[ __ ] Lea eight jokes a minute and I
mean they were all good and you just
kill and kill and kill and then when you
got to take a breath he would take a
breath yeah and let them breathe there's
people that tell those short jokes are
the ones that like I'm so amazed by cuz
you have to write so many jokes to fill
a half hour an hour it's like when
you're storytelling like you know that's
an art to figure out like how to take
people on this ride but when you have to
write a hundred and fifty jokes because
you're telling you know however many a
minute yeah like LPS yeah but you know
what's so funny I'm not trying to like
poop one my own kind of you know
performance but a storyteller it's like
the Johnny Carson approach where I think
it's a lot more about personality and I
mean you gotta have the the laughs in
there of course but you can get away
with so much more in terms of just like
they like the swagger they like to this
they like that I'm gonna slow down and
be like hey shut the [ __ ] up over there
come out of the character go back in
when you're the LPM joke guy that's it
that's it if you're killing with just
that with it with no frills that that's
very important and the economy of war I
hate to say that that word economy but
it's amazing like I would look at your
your book an economy of words an economy
of words Rodney I'm Rodney's stuff was
so perfectly were like no extra word
nothing like nothing like I'll add words
because I just took Pat it or to make it
like if you're doubting something I'll
throw in were but like just [ __ ] did
you
for them no I met him why he was on a1a
we interviewed him once I don't know I
never know never should have you never
heard Rodney Dangerfield go ah what else
right you know what I mean like those
moments unless it was part of the like
ya know what's going on but I was at the
factory laughs factory in LA when I
first got there in like 98 so rodney was
like popping in a lot and there was a
thing that I had to do cuz I would host
a lot of shows and they they be like
Ronnie's coming in okay and you had a
certain thing that he had to do with
Rodney and what you do is he sit at the
booth and I'd have to go on stage and I
did this maybe like 40 or 50 times over
the course of a few years that he popped
in I go ladies and gentlemen there's a
absolute icon in the room ladies and
gentlemen
Rodney Dangerfield and ridings like in
let them go let them you know make some
noise and of course they go crazy yeah
they're gone [ __ ] apeshit screaming
and bonkers
and and then he would stand up and kind
of like half stand up like I'm just I'm
just gonna wave and then you'd have to
go Rodney Rodney would you come up here
for a few minutes for us Ronnie and
there's a place ago and they really
liked and the Gary Glitter comes out in
his life and so and then Rodney would
would kind of like throw the hands like
no no I can't I can't do that and then
you say it one more time so it's like
the classic comedy 3 do we want to see
Rodney like like you're making Rodney
right yeah and then he'd come up and do
it in one night I finally had the the
balls to be like Ronnie like why not
just walk up yeah it was a thing of you
just wanted to hear do you wanted to
hear it you want me to do well on stage
crush yeah
kill it but it is amazing that even at
the level he had that insecurity of
being like no I need to hear that they
definitely want me before I go up there
yeah like that's amazing material was
very universal like you very much why
all it didn't matter it was just funny
no everybody loves right but it was also
like one of the few I don't know I saw a
lot of people coming in and out of
Boston New York coming up so I kind of
got used to seeing like oh that's but
seeing him standing on stage was like my
whole like childhood just it was amazing
to be in a room with with that guy me
and Florentine went summit Avery Fisher
Hall the night that we interviewed
because I wanted to be in the room with
him once when he
formed that was what he was really old
it was like the boy was a little harder
to hear him because he was an older guy
and but it was it didn't matter who you
were still just watching Rodney do
stand-up live yeah I knew it would be
the only time I ever saw that it was
there was the only thing that it's like
we wouldn't be comics if we didn't haze
on each other a little bit but I
remember one time he came in he have an
earpiece and his wife we you know kind
of feed him jokes what's wrong but every
once while the the something wouldn't
connect and it was like an animal you
like a tronic Rodney where you just see
him just and he'd be like and you just
see him kind of waiting you know or you
know she'd be upstairs like my wife is
it and there would be this weird like
via satellite you know fat jokes there's
nothing better huh he could it's funny
half the stuff he did today people would
object to of course a body shaming yeah
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]